and all singing all dancing extravaganza
filled with wild heard little creatures
that live in a fuzzy world packed with
color and sparkle that stream works
latest animated movie trolls starring
Anna Kendrick and Justin Timberlake
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll go through
revealing loads of crazy fun facts about
the movie including a bunch of Easter
eggs just before I start I'm running a
giveaway for this gorgeous hardback book
from Tyson called the art of DreamWorks
trolls which is full of concept and
production art and info on the movie all
you need to do for a chance to win a
copy is subscribe and leave a comment or
reply to a comment about the film on
this video and because you guys are so
awesome I've even got a bunch of bonus
ways to enter the giveaway so check out
the gleam link in the video description
below for more details ok now let's take
a look at 15 crazy fun facts and easter
eggs in the movie trolls because hair is
such an important and distinctive part
of how the trolls lurk the animators
wanted to make sure they got it just
right in the movie so they filmed
slow-motion footage of the original
troll toys and used it as a reference to
see how their hair moved in fact the
movie had a dedicated her task force
with hundreds of artists and technicians
working solely on her effects and the
DreamWorks tech team even created a
brand new piece a software called willow
to help make it easier for the movie's
artists to style simulate and preview
the trolls hair in total the animators
created 1.8 million strands of hair for
the movie to give you an idea of how
that works out for the individual
characters poppy has almost 84,000
strands while branch has nearly 50,000
strands but the character who has the
most hair on her head is Lady glitter
sparkles whose overall style is pure 70s
disco diva and whose rainbow wig is made
up of over 230,000 strands but even lady
glitter sparkles can't compete with a
number of strands required to create the
hair plus all the fur on the giraffe
like troll Cooper because his head and
body took over 800,000 strands
not only did the movies crew have their
work cut out creating masses of
super-powered troll hair for the film
they also had to deal with tons of
glitter and that was not easy as their
computers could only make glitter look
realistic when it was motionless and not
when it was moving around and reflecting
light as it needed to do in the movie to
solve this sparkly problem DreamWorks
tech team put on their thinking hats
again and invented another new piece of
software the glitter flake shader which
made glitter flakes in the movie look
randomly scattered about as it naturally
look in real life but also allowed the
movie's artist to easily manipulate
their movement shape and reflectiveness
if there's one thing that isn't sparkly
in the trolls movie it's the unhappy
ogre like bergens when the animators
were designing the gloomy land where the
bergens live they turned to 1970s
suburbia pit inspiration which is why
the Bergin's world is mainly colored in
earth tones like shades of burnt orange
dark green and gold and that's also why
Bergen town is influenced by popular
1970s things like shag carpets wood
paneling polyester Formica and bruselas
architecture but the 1970s wasn't the
only era that influenced the look of
Bergen town the animators also looked
back much further to the Middle Ages and
used the layout of walled medieval
villages as a reference for how they
arranged Bergen town although the
technology exists to make animated
movies look more photorealistic than
ever before think of the landscapes in
Pixar's the good dinosaur for example
the filmmakers behind trolls wanted
their movie to have a very handmade
textured feel so to achieve that they
based the film's look on felt fabrics
and fiber art which means that when the
animators were creating the trolls super
fuzzy world things like macrame felting
techniques flopped material velvet and
knitting were all a big influence on its
look and to give the crew a proper feel
for how the trolls world should look the
film's production designer asked IO
based artists eye Ori Sasaki Hermann to
create a model of the troll forest as it
just fiber and fabrics the hit song
can't stop the feeling was co-written by
Justin Timberlake who voices branch to
resolve a problem the filmmakers were
having with how to change the Bergin's
gloom outlook and bring the film to
satisfying clothes the directors didn't
like the idea of the Bergin's being
and swarmed after hearing a character
given motivational speech and they
couldn't find a song to fit the moment
so they asked Timberlake to write a song
that would have the right effect and
can't stop the feeling was the result as
director Mike Mitchell says the song
creates happiness when you hear it so it
makes sense that it would bring the
trolls and burgers together in the movie
and in keeping with the movies 1970s
feel Timberlake who's also the film's
executive music producer channels a mix
of Michael Jackson the Bee Gees and Bill
Withers when he was writing the song
when it came to getting the right vibe
between poppy and branches start off as
polar opposites and are both very
determined characters the filmmakers
took cues from the classic 80s action
comedy Romancing the Stone specifically
the on-screen energy and back-and-forth
between its stars Kathleen Turner and
Michael Douglas in fact Romancing the
Stone is actually one of director Mike
Mitchell's favorite movies according to
the directors of trolls their movies
strange fairy tale-like dream quality
owes a great deal to the odd creatures
and dreamlike worlds created by renowned
Japanese rice director Hayao Miyazaki
who co-founded Studio Ghibli and gave us
such classic animated movies as spirited
away and for the scene where poppy sings
the sound of silence accompanied by a
variety of weird and wonderful creatures
and plant life the filmmakers channels
not only miyazaki was also the animated
TV show Adventure Time and director Mike
Mitchell has said that in this scene
poppy is like a quirky twist on Snow
White or Cinderella who are friendly
with all the forest creatures at the
start of the movie when chef plucks what
she believes to be a troll from the
troll tree for the young prince crystal
to eat the Bergin's are all horrified to
discover that it's not a real live troll
but a wooden one as the real trolls have
cunningly escaped this moment is a
lovely Easter egg contributor thomas dam
the danish creator of the original trial
toys the movies based on as the first
funny little figures that he created
were carved out of wood and it was a
popularity of those wood carvings that
led dam to create the very first troll
toys we know today and as a little
easter egg and Amash the troll dolls it
became so popular in the 1960s and often
didn't wear any clothes the filmmakers
invented a character for the movie
called guy diamond who's naked except
for glitter by the way the character of
guy Dimond is voiced by the Big Bang
Theory's Kunal Nayyar
trolls also makes references to a number
of other movies and stories for example
when poppy leaves the 12 village and
heads to Bergen town to save her friends
she crosses paths with a bunch of
spiders and falls through a series of
webs getting completely wrapped up in
one of them that scene in the movie
really tips his hat to Peter Jackson's
movie the hobbit the desolation of Smaug
and in turn of course to jr. are
Tolkien's original novel The Hobbit and
as the scene were scullery maid Bridget
who's disguised as Lady glitter sparkles
is on a date with King grissle jr. and
she gets all tongue-tied so the trolls
help her out telling her what to say
well that scene is a nod to the French
place around a de Bergerac which has
been adapted in many movies over the
years including the 1987 hit comedy
Roxanne starring Steve Martin and Daryl
Hannah and when lady glitter sparkles
accidentally leaves behind one of her
roller skates after her date with King
gristle jr. is a clear shout-out to the
story of Cinderella which has also been
adapted for the big screen many times
including Disney's recent live-action
version with Lily James and Richard
Madden and Anna Kendrick also played
Cinderella in Disney's version of into
the woods
speaking of roller skating for the
design of Captain Star funcles the
filmmakers took cues from moonlight
rollaway a roller skating rink which is
just a stone's throw from the DreamWorks
Animation offices in Glendale California
and actually the movies crew went
skating there several times when they
were making the film as well as Co
directing the movie Walt Dohrn also lent
his voice to a number of small
characters including smidge who's a
little troll with a very deep voice
mister dinkles whose big E's pet worm
first burped a troll who's mostly hair
with a pair of feet sticking out and
cloud guy the white stop wearing walking
talking cloud who loves high-fiving
everyone Dawn's co-director Mike
Mitchell also stepped into the sound
booth to record various voices to the
film including a spider and captain star
funcle' who serves pizza to King Drasil
jr. and Lady glitter sparkles during
their date now who's your favorite
character in trolls and what would you
like to see happen in a troll sequel
tell me in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe and comment for your
chance to win this gorgeous hardback
book the art of true works trolls for
bonus ways to enter the giveaway do
check out the gleam link in the video
description below so guys if you liked
this video do also check out my trolls
movie review and my animation playlist
here
I always appreciate your like shares and
comments on my videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers